noticias de la economía con Daniela
Blandón en directo América Daniela
Buendía para usted Hola Buenos días
Ángela seguimos haciendo la tarea de
preparación por el aniversario de la
guerra en Ucrania y esta semana vamos a
analizar el discurso de Vladimir Putin
entre otras cosas que pronunció hace
algunas horas Cuáles fueron los aspectos
económicos de esta intervención Ángela
Pues el presidente ruso aprovechó una
parte de su discurso para llamar a los
oligarcas nacionales a invertir y hacer
negocios en el país pues según él
aquellos que sacaron sus capitales al
extranjero han perdido mucho de hecho
varios de ellos han sido objeto de
sanciones un tema al que también le
dedicó parte de su intervención
no han logrado sus objetivos y no lo
harán además quienes iniciaron las
sanciones se han castigado a sí mismos
han provocado aumentos de precios
cierres de empresas y una crisis
energética en sus países
y les dicen a sus propios ciudadanos que
los rusos tienen la culpa de todo han
tratado de romper los lazos económicos
con las empresas rusas aislar el sistema
financiero ruso privarnos del acceso a
los mercados de exportación para golpear
nuestros ingresos
también está el robo porque no hay otra
manera de llamarlo de nuestras reservas
de Divisas intentos de socavar El rublo
y provocar inflaciones las sanciones
contra Rusia son solo una herramienta el
objetivo como ellos mismos declaran es
hacer sufrir a nuestros ciudadanos
pues él dice que su economía resistió
porque occidente esperaba que el pib
cayera entre el 20 y el 25% pues lo hizo
en 2,1% en 2022 sin embargo las cifras
más recientes muestran que en enero de
este año los ingresos Fiscales de ese
país cayeron en un 35% y que su déficit
presupuestario asciende a más de 24.000
millones de dólares hay más noticias en
Francia el presidente defendió su
reforma pensional es de una forma bien
particular Así es Ángela pues estuvo
Manuel macron esta mañana de visita en
una plaza de Mercado llamada en donde de
inmediato fue cuestionado por su muy
controvertida reforma que suscita
hostilidad no solamente en las calles
sino también en el parlamento y que
pretende recordemos lo Elevar la edad de
pensión de 62 a 64 años Pues esta fue la
explicación que les dio
una del sistema Es simple tenemos un
sistema que valoramos que es un tesoro
significa que todos paguen la jubilación
de sus mayores y luego sus hijos pagarán
su jubilación Ese es el sistema de
reparto no un sistema de capitalización
donde usted paga su propia pensión no es
complicado decir que tenemos menos
trabajadores que hace 20 años tenemos
más pensionistas y vivimos más entonces
no es cierto que podemos mantener las
mismas edades eso no funciona entonces
la gente que empieza a trabajar muy
temprano con carreras largas quienes
trabajan de noche en el frío con cargas
pesadas tenemos en cuenta estas
diferencias en el cálculo pero en
general la gente sabe que tiene que
trabajar un poco más en promedio porque
de lo contrario no podremos financiar
nuestras pensiones adecuadamente
Bueno ya veremos Si la gente le cree a
esta a esta explicación y recordemos que
hay una gran movilización programada
para el próximo 7 de marzo por este
proyecto y aquí estaremos nosotros para
hacer el cubrimiento en otros temas
Daniela una tragedia familiar en Estados
Unidos se ha convertido en un caso
simbólico Por decirlo menos contra Los
Gigantes tecnológicos claro la historia
es la siguiente este caso es muy
mediático Tiene como demandantes a
familiares de personas que fallecieron
en los ataques del estado islámico en
París en 2015 Pues liderados por la
familia de una de las víctimas Noemí
González afirman que el algoritmo de
YouTube de Google radicalizó a las
personas para convertirlas en
terroristas y por eso acusan a la red
social de fomentar esta actividad lo
cual es ilegal Según la ley de Estados
Unidos el escudo legal de estas empresas
es conocido como la sección 230 que dice
que las compañías de tecnología y sitios
web no pueden ser considerados
responsables del contenido creado por
sus usuarios como lo explica a
continuación una experta
desde 1996 la sección 230 ha permitido
que las empresas de internet están
relativamente libres de regulación o
responsabilidad por el contenido
producido por los usuarios esencialmente
dice que la función de las plataformas
tecnológicas como Google Uber airbnb o
eBay es Conectar a las personas entonces
si sucede algo malo como una venta que
sale mal en Ebay esta empresa no es
responsable la noticia acá es que está
previsto que para este martes la Corte
Suprema de Justicia escuche los
argumentos de las familias después de
que les fuera negada la demanda en
primera instancia en todo caso de la
primera vez que el alto tribunal examina
el alcance de esta sección 230 tan
polémica pues va a ser muy llamativo
porque seguro va a marcar un referente
importante en el manejo de internet de
las redes sociales gracias a usted
Daniela bueno la cifra tiene que ver con
redes sociales y se la tengo para la
segunda Crónica pues acá la espero